hello everyone welcome
to the press room of the
european commission thank you also dismissed
follow live online and on you buy
sattelite today monday november 22
at the holding
of
the quentris diet meeting rather than my guy
based on  crysis nitride on the belarusian regime lease list
then, like every week, two
plenary sessions of the european parliament the
college of commissioners is meeting
tomorrow tuesday in strasbourg and following the
meeting of the chiefs of staff which took
place this morning i can now
announce the  agenda of the college therefore the
files that the colleges will discuss
tomorrow therefore 10 and the college will discuss
first of all the European response
to the actions of the Belarusian regime on the
external border of the European union
as well as the possibility of setting
up  measures against
transport operators who are complicit in the
trafficking of people to
the european union this file will be
the subject of c  report of the college which
will take place therefore despite strasbourg
immediately after the intervention of the
president melt the hatred in the
plenary of the european parliament on these
subjects
then the commissioners will discuss
the time package of the european semester
which will be presented to you here in the meeting room
press by executive vice presidents
dombrowski ce and commissioners
is he honni and schmidt wednesday at
1pm the same day so on wednesday we will be
holding a technical briefing for you
about the 1st semester
the technical briefing will be offered to kate
and will have  take place at
10:30 a.m.
shooting
[Music]
at the
local elections the action elle fanning to the public
[Music]
at the
program
[Music]
the
surroundings of future residents
not
[Music]
how mr lukashenko and trade unionists
the bataves in very clear and in saint
gaudens few days to your reer going to
do when it comes to you without assistance
to contributions tomat  is ovingdean
artificial is credited with 46 between
the number
of contacts minister
mackay
of the
technical vikings
christofer hoff of companies out of ten
in contact
[Music]
effective
brutt
movements of any movement
[Music]
each  from them
the cases
of the
[Music]
scientists
september
nixon evil hysterical
background do you have any news
about the authorization of the vaccine buy
out of hype serves for children from 5 to
11 years old in germany  is indeed the
minister of health sir fans
have just announced the distribution for
December 20
that the commission and the patients are doing
thank you
cm1 who is trying to analyze the file and
in fact recognized his opinion but stéphane
what is it  that's exactly it that's
exactly it on your question
what does the commission do is the
commission it follows the recommendations
and the life of the ema the biotech company will
introduce  a request for
the authorization of the market of the product
for children from 5 to 11 years old we know
that the hands is in the process of evaluating
this this request and we
understand that the ema will come with its
position soon but with
regard to  the timing I obviously invite you
to contact les
mots, which is an independent agency
and which ensures the evaluation of
the workforce, the effectiveness and safety
of vaccines,
thank you very much stéphane,
so we are left with the questions related
to the qu  'ovid and vaccines for stéphane
I see a lot of them in our chat so
I'll give the floor to martin
whitmarsh
has
built not built
[Music]
in germany we are already announcing the
distribution of vaccines which is not
yet authorized in europe is what
sir span more information than
you that the ema is what the commission
is not the guardian of the treaties is what
it should not ensured that this
kind of the wedding did not hold did that
it creates a lot  expectations  in germany
and everyone is talking about it so it's
really over the moon so I think
the commission has something to say about it
thank you thank you very much for your question
eric
as stéphane just said it's
another european agency for
drugs
to approve to approve to give a market
and conditional authorization for these
vaccines so let's be clear about the
responsibilities that we have vis-à-vis
our agencies but also vis-à-vis the
national level it is that belongs to the
national competences  to prepare
logistically for the possible
distribution
of vaccines an anti sipa a possible
market authorization which should
come from the emas and therefore it is entirely
the responsibility of the two
national or regional or local authorities
if necessary depending on how the
e health systems are organized in
our member states to take preparatory parts
to prepare the logistics
of a vaccination before
we  let's support the vaccination of the
adult population which started as you know
after this canon December 1,
2020 we encouraged member states
to prepare logistically
because as you know to be
effective in moving forward quickly and
the importance of putting in the logistics  in
place but we don't have another
comment any other comments to
make on the preparations that are taking place
at the national level just beyond the fact
that it is important to always be
logistically prepared for other
elements just wanted  added
that indeed it is very important that
the member states get ready and go
quickly but on the other side the
commission also works very
quickly you know that once we
get the green light from the ema the
commission to procedures  ultra fast
which allows the the commission adopted
the decision which allows the placing on the
market of the vaccine or the placing or
rather the authorization of the vaccine it
is something that we have  done within 24
hours in most of the
previous cases so we can work
quickly on our side also
the scientific opinion of the ema does
he have any other questions on this subject the
patricia
paquin vaccine which
[Music]
dope
the pipettes processing a
major gain this major conflict
[Music]
law news
n
[Music]
including fortis
independent
specific
laval
of course we see date to build
can't beat them  all
[Music]
in you can't feel to
live with a flu trends one
or two next
short distance contracts
match
and funny situation
question was your question
related to that
yes hello actually actually i have one
question which is a bit of a
perplexity
stéphane said maxime is vaccinated
vaccinate we are on the third dose we
are considering the third
dose I wanted to know why we need
a third dose
is what we are getting  prepare
for a fourth dose in six months
how to explain that after six months
the flip-flop protections so easily
we have people who do tests and who
discover that they have been vaccinated
twice and that they have a protection rate
that has  completely and drastically
reduced that after six months you have to be
ready quickly for a new dose and in
conclusion
I would like to come back to your
communication campaign dana which is that of
Mrs von der leyen who announced to us that
we have 70% of the population of  places who
are vaccinated that's it it's good and in
fact not at all how do you
explain that with 70 depending on the
population of the european union to
vaccinate we are obliged today to
resume restrictive measures we
is an outbreak of the pandemic we
have to plan a third is
planned a fourth dose worse there is
a feeling of panic that is
being created with a big doubt about the
vaccination people are  t more and
more perplexed on the need for
vaccination what you are
aware of it I understood a little in your
answer to my colleagues that
indeed you find legitimate the
demonstrations simply the
demonstrations they are very hard cd
very violent demonstrations and c  it's
a demonstration that takes place on
political consequences so I would like to
know if you understand this whole
dimension or if you continue to
think like a frank technocrat
thank you very much for your series of
questions christian is
indeed very complex questions and
allows  between stéphane and me
to provide some answers but
frankly some of these
questions are better addressed to experts
and scientists who will
provide us with answers soon perhaps
even this week because we talk about
the fact that  here from here our agency
and emma good maybe
fr announcements on the files they are
studying da  n the days to come so
on vaccination
indeed christian
we are ready to repeat as
often as possible that vaccination
is an important means
to fight this pandemic
you mentioned it yourself we have
established ambitious objectives for the
vaccination of the population  european
we have progressed very well or fairly
quickly to achieve our
objectives we are today
beyond 76% if
if my memories are good of the
adult population in europe which was
vaccinated with two doses therefore with a
primary complete vaccination and  we continue to
believe that we must we must we must
continue to vaccinate to
further reduce the possibilities that the virus has
to spread
it is important to make the difference
or who to establish what is the role
of a  vaccine but once again
for that our colleagues from el himma and from
here 10 are better placed to lead these
important debates with you but a
vaccine must happen  obviously reduce the
risk of contamination
but it must also reduce symptoms
or the severity of the symptoms
that a person would have if ever this
thinks 7 7 people still catch
this virus so the debate on immunity
how long it lasts and why
would we have  boosters are needed and
why some member states have
obviously decided this is a debate that
we are following is therefore in which
we are very deeply involved
but once again we are waiting for a
clear answer based on scientific evidence
and on the data that is
coming  from the agencies stéphane
i'm sure you have a
lot added to that no i think you want
to explain the gist i
maybe just wanted to emphasize
again that what is already
clear on  numbers and
again we are awaiting more information
from the ancient
aecid ema collections here but what is already clear
is that the more  vaccination
less there is hospitalization - there are
mortality rates so it is very
important these figures are already there and
are very clear it is true we are
obviously continuing once again
with the help of scientists to
verify the duration  of effectiveness of
vaccines does not yield it duration of effectiveness
is great but for certain
categories we see after a certain
time that the facts the effectiveness is
still there but
reduced a little bit which is one of the
reasons why the  cd and
hands once again launched
opinions on the boost and the third
dose
finally I would like to emphasize once
again the importance of not forgetting
the importance of
non-pharmaceutical interventions precisely to lift the
non-pharmaceutical interventions very
early  can lead like the cds if it
indicated on September 30 to an
increase in infections of which all these elements must be
taken into consideration
but it is clear on the basis of the
studies  elements that we already have that the vaccine
is vaccination is a very
important element to reduce the number of
number of cases of hospitalization and the
number and the turn of mortality
completely stéphane jetté so just
two things in conclusion yes we  we have
roughly two-thirds of the
European population if you
also include the children who are vaccinated
but we still have everyone who is not
vaccinated that's that's a lot that's a
lot of citizens who are not
vaccinated so  viruses can spread
very quickly in these environments,
secondly, we still have
very significant and quite
striking differences between the
vaccination rates of our member countries,
with countries that are above 90%
and others that are below the  30%
so there too it is important
to remedy this because viruses
can develop much more
easily in homes where there are
large numbers of people who who who are
not  not vaccinated there may be
new variants that emerge and
thirdly as stéphane has
just said the correlation between
vaccination figures and the severity
of symptoms including
hospitalizations
and mortality rates is very clear
and we will soon publish
figures is who and who
would perhaps also help you to bring your reflections
between
the effectiveness
on the effectiveness of vaccines by
correlating precisely the rate of
vaccinations and the hospitalizations and
the mortality rates in the
member countries  has any others and questions
about this
i think so
in the clouds
if you could find your makers
[Music]
then the question is probably
can you hear
me thanks i apologize if you answered
this question  maybe because I
took two the current briefing but I
would like to know the reaction of
the European commission to know if
you were challenged by the fact that at the
m  anifestation rotterdam friday
night police fired live ammunition
targeting protesters
three protesters were injured according
to latest latest
information police admit they did so because is
the
situation dangerous
that there was a disease that he  there was a
lot of violence
the authorities justified
his shooting
I would like to know if you consider
that
by proceeding in this way the Dutch police are
respecting the values ​​and the
rules of the rule of law
this coming from a country which has the notion
of the rule of law that she does not carry very
high as a standard here I would like to
know if shooting at demonstrators who
obviously as far as we know
were not themselves armed did
not themselves shoot at the police it  is
acceptable thank you thank you very much to the
very relevant question and in a
minute I will call adalbert to give you
the position but like stéphane and on
the podiums I would like to know if there are
any  very questions that would be addressed to
him on the health aspects of the
kovy crisis in so i don't know if éric
bones to questions on that
copenhagen by michael
jackson gave everything
this weekend are ten actions said
m
[Music  ]
eric coisne
we
didn't walk earlier I just wanted
to bounce back circulate on a
remark stéphane he just said the
duration of effectiveness of vaccines is
grumbling but reduced a little bit but
it's surprising to hear you say  that
since for astrazeneca paca for
example we have just learned that
the effectiveness is assured for only
four months there are millions and
millions of Europeans who have received two doses
of astrazeneca and who are in a
situation
of concern now because  that they no
longer know if this vaccine still works
if they are considered unvaccinated
this must be relaxed ine and when it
will be possible in Belgium for example we
have learned from the government that it will be
possible until April s  only and at the
same time you are going to recommend the
vaccination of small children so I no
longer see the logic and I no longer see the
strategy the last thank you
so much the basic strategy is
simple you have to get vaccinated it's as
simple as that if we  vaccine have
reduced the risk of hospitalization have
reduced the risk of mortality it's
simple and 11 and secondly we
continue to follow the
scientific work of our colleagues were going
wrong here from here who also
obviously follow the duration of the effectiveness of
vaccines  and based on the
information we have at this time but
again emma and and 6 deaths are
following the situation and will come
soon we hope with
new ideas new
recommendations and new since its
week 10 if the hands have indicated
that  the vaccine effectiveness rate
remains very high at more than 80% there is
the obvious there is scientific evidence
here and there that demonstrates a
slight reduction in  protection but
again that's not to say that
the vaccine would lose altogether that to
quote vaccines are effective are
crucial are needed in our
fight against the vaccine second to
third and fourth no we
the masts and the cdc  are we noticed
have
launched or rather offer
opinions opinions concerning the use of
booster precisely with the aim of helping to
strengthen the immunity of people whose
immune system is less
developed and therefore for whom it would be
good to have a  booster to strengthen
the immunity of these people and I think
that is the case in which we
work but again it is
very important that we follow we
continue to follow the indications of
the scientific world and that is what we
let's do in the meantime now more
elements of the image the cdc thank you
very much stéphane and eric and for the
other colleagues who are obviously interested in
this very important debate
what is essential to
underline is that it is a situation
which evolves quickly the situation that we quickly
but also
the scientific data and the
scientific evidence also evolves we
gain more experience and we
have more and more  more data to
look at and therefore the recommendations
and advice that our specialist agencies
can give is also evolving as
we said we expect
there to be a new risk is at this point
from our agencies that will be presented
maybe  later this week in
the days to come and in view of
your legitimate and complex questions on these
subjects, we will try to organize a
technical briefing
for you with our agencies to be able to
enter in more detail the cdc questions
which are acquired are relevant on
the evolution of the pandemic and
our responses
is there any other questions
about this I see a few raised hands
so marco from florida lloris
[Music]
ok sorry  but my camera does not work
I question this certifies that an empty shot
because when it is effective well was
introduced you decided to
also give to people who were not
vaccinated because at that time many
people did not have  still access to
vaccines and therefore
there could be
discrimination and therefore for these people
there was
the possibility of having the
certificate with a test now
everyone was entitled to honda accents
in the european union
do you think that  is the time to make
a distinction by giving a 10 at
least rights to citizens who have a
only a test and who do not have the
vaccines or do you believe that with
regard to the certificate and with
regard to what is  your competence i
am referring to travel between countries of
the european union i am not repeating myself to the
measures that will be introduced in
mans states but with regard to
travel is what you still believe
that
having a test don  do not have the same right as
having as a vaccine thank you thank you
very much for your questions marking
once again they are relevant
and complex allow me
to give a very quick summary
of the system and the different
responsibilities that are in place to
manage this crisis  is this pandemic
we have proposed a tool at
European level which moreover works well
for the for the purposes for which it
was created and to facilitate the free
movement of people in europe in
safe conditions
but at the same time it is  to the
member states at national level
to establish relevant rules
with regard to health and the
possibilities of vaccinations allow
me to also say that there are also
people who leave from a medical point of view
cannot be vaccinated
so we must  that they understand a
position at the national level
differentiate
the disappointed and that for now there is
no like we have 10 1
a va  ccin which has been approved for
children so it needs to
be clear be the art with all the
elements that are relevant i
also said a start of our
discussion which we will be coming up with
in the days to come and i will be in
position to confirm the details and
the date we have proposed
changes a hurricane recommendations
it under the free movement of
people
but this should not anticipate in
any way the content of these
recommendations so we are looking at
the developments which is that we must
bring in
order to continue to facilitate the
movement of people but for the
details that it contains and in
which direction we are going
please wait name dating from our
proposals
stéphane do you have anything to
add on the common elements  clerks
on the table no
are there any other questions about this
the health aspects of bullfights
ask
forgeries one was compromised in.  ur
of the causes
which conceived other of his colleagues
arises
as a creative community
yes how to
position for
scientist  back
excerpts from my
six deaths and 2.5 in
2006 on people like you and me out at
8.5 euros
enzo images but distinction between
people insights beavogui scientist in
the next floor
questions to
me stéphane quickly because you did
n't answer  to eric's question on
astrazeneca you validated this vaccine
is whether you were informed
about the duration of its protection and had
four months and not six since it
changes a lot of things in belgium
it was almost imposed for  a whole
category of people we had no
choice and we were forced to be
vaccinated with astrazeneca simondi six
months or four months these two months of
beating two months  during
which people who have the two doses can
be contaminated if by misfortune they are in
contact with people who are not
vaccinated thank
you thank you very much but when the vaccines
are approved by the hands the hands
checks a whole series of things which we
have  do the expected duration
of effectiveness or efficacy of the vaccine
they do that with all the vaccines of which
it is the hands who are first who
are best placed to give you an
approach or a vision a
scientific opinion on the duration of  effectiveness
of the vaccines in any case when
we approved the vaccines it was
because the vaccines were clearly
indicated as being effective it had a
very high rate of effectiveness and we
obviously continue to follow the
scientific elements and it is above all
our  colleagues the maquis continues
to do it but I can't say more
about the number of months here and there that
unfortunately it's a little out of our
competence we depend for  that of
the input and the ideas
of the scientists the expertized
earlier indeed of the scientists thank you
very much stéphane I think that this is where
concludes the series of questions on the
health aspects of the empty
coa for stéphane dussault five matches with the aces  we
know it
[Music]
clean
thank you dana and thank you I think
it was who asked this question
concerning the demonstrations
specifically in rotterdam I'm going to
have to give you a
relatively general answer since the
commission is not  not on the ground
not being a police force is
not the best placed to
understand specific situations
what is important for the commission
is a certain number of principles that
dana recalled the right to
peaceful demonstrations
as well as obviously respect for
fundamental rights in general and the
proportionality of any response spoken
by the forces of order, that said, the
maintenance or safeguard of public
order  blic is very firmly a
national competence of the member states it is
exercised under the control of the
national courts and the commission as I
said is not not well placed to
comment on two specific situations
whatever one
[Music]
says match of this
phase i
yes thank you adalbert however when your
answer
but dallas I think that this question
is also addressed to you as
spokesperson for the beyond of the president
because madam wendel rihanna
also finds that it is only the question
of the  rule of law still very
important she often talks about it she
says she defends the rule of law so here
I am restating my question really with
this idea in mind does
shooting live ammunition at
demonstrators come within the framework of respect
of the rule of law or does that
raise questions is that the presidency
little and we the commission can within the
framework in particular of the views on the
right job ask these questions and
have  answers go above thank
you thank you very much alain but you will not
be surprised if I tell you that the
president does not have a fine a
different position from the commission because
you can ask the question specifically
that her personal opinion
whereas we  have given the position of the
commission the president as the
commission finds that violence has
no place in our societies is in
relation to a demonstration
but to investigate and to understand
what happened during a
specific demonstration such as  which is the
one they took place in in
rotterdam last weekend it is the
national courts which are competent to see
if the rules have been respected
which way of the proportionality
of the intervention and all these elements
which  are which are which are relevant
but there is nothing I can add to
these that we have already said several
times today that the right has organized
to participate in demonstrations.
it's part of the fundamental rights
that we have here in europe
but that violence cannot be
has no place in our societies and
during these demonstrations
specifically to understand what
happened and to take
possible actions in relation to
demonstrations like the one we had in
rotterdam it is the authorities and the
national courts which are competent to
investigate and give answers
thank you very much is there any other
question for adalbert  for the
topics it covers
I don't see any thank you very much
adalbert is there anything else for
us today ah sorry before I
give the floor to the theme
team to provide
and freedom in egypt
genco
shipping
and the the
next co presidency
and
m
[Music]
non au bac very
newly I was giving a look
everything is fake tofu la botte de ronan
thomas de cory jane do you say there
will be package discussed in et à tous
d  there it is  ire of surviving action
without transparency or act i know why
is it reading rich right now what
are problem of philosophers to action
be late thing to be packages
going to cover of secret story l  summer
all in gray prime minister out
of trailer of all actions
lateral union leaders moreover well
bootleg commission everything is in
suspense or
proceedings ding fring proceedings
tar heel it had to meager
sovereignty all in gray where the  current
if you russia
nintendo computers european
commission everything is possible it's
not major of
[Music]
the action
they
have reason to be happy
go ahead
these  developments have raised bruised
but stuck tray
disposal
by
a caste diverse
of emotion
but not a precise idea of ​​china in
chile made
you development cld its
makers on the one
hand
explained
the other noureddine fire
in the first aid to bring  back to back
on track
yes oh so if you to win 8-3 case
state manager on buy canada yes yes
develop opposed young people in situation
and where we of this date is
important of course the prime minister
the transition
the action is stable  of bing prime
minister
important yes a chorister quaritch
straw of rice nude commitment to of
twenty nine
constitutional of carresse the hearing of
course walkom of released from the rest
of dr amdocs bat we do the joy of course
the immediate release of all à deux
poules and  eton school is not only in
khartoum defeats one or two people who
were at the top crucial steps ristori
below unconstitutional provisions
other and love lot of
peaceful sudan and 2 and st john the next
steps
migration of the people including this
jane hole include  and the prodigy
remaining transition let's not forget
est date we continue to great and kind
m long on the spot
viber
in the zone of protesters and
enjoyed it and
we call soi  t com de com and man with the
stig and death and in there is among
professed protestors under
investigation bi zoro independent agency
by
[Music]
a sudden
who
is he
but he is
[Music]
yet
possible
[Music]
mobile was
[  Music]
[Music]
slain